[Music]
what's up y'all one of the best things
about both stargate sg1 and stargate
atlantis is that you the fans always
have a chance to win a part on the show
i ran into dude from small town
wisconsin and he was like i'm in this
next scene i was like what
he was
[Music]
i'm nathan flaminio i'm from wausau
wisconsin and i won the get in the gate
contest
uh and here we are on the set of
stargate sg1 i got to meet him and he
was very sweet
um blonde and jerk
the costume that they originally had me
in on was running up the hill over there
and i stepped on it and it ripped right
off of me
now
we have actually got
live from the web questions from you to
us
this is the must-know stuff so the first
question
off the internet
is christopher
to right now but uh nonetheless
fascinating history where can i get
stargate bedding bookstore
video shops i don't know how did the
ancients set up the gates with just
jumpers having a clue i have no idea
what does nid stand for
nid
carter is hot
zoom in on that carter is hot
where did major davis go in season seven
to his trailer when are we going to hear
taylor sing when hell freezes over i'm
hoping it's
the 10th 11th season or something i saw
daniel reunite with sarah am i behind
well david he looks playing it i don't
think how is anubis defeated was he when
will jack and sam kiss
i think she might have a bit of a thing
for mckay i don't know something about
his belly it's a prickly relationship
that has romantic possibilities let's
put it that way possibly they
might
actually end up together
and then there's a surprise twist
nice job rick stargate action figures
would you buy them
my action figure is just going to be the
shaquille o'neal action figure that they
paint a little gold symbol on but i
think the key to being less annoying is
if you were more annoying
then i would seem less annoying now i've
talked to rainbow and to rachel about
this and i haven't actually got around
to you yet right um because you're so
busy
ow
i kiss it better no
just don't do it again hey michael i
really appreciate you sitting down with
me and agreeing to this interview i know
after the thing that occurred with conan
with your part being cut out
that i thought maybe there was a little
you know problems there it's one thing
to go on national tv and diss on the
character and even though i blew you
away in that sequence we shot somehow it
just ended up with your face being on
that screen somehow i was cut out of the
entire thing i mean can you explain that
to jackson
[Music]
is there a time limit to this
or anything no yeah
why are you bored already no i'm not
bored i'm just
you know
what my questions aren't good enough for
you they're fine
they're really they're really good
you know i have conan's ear i can easily
get back on conan and
work on you some more
i guess there's one thing i really want
to i don't really want to know but i
guess i should ask how's pete
[Music]
stay tuned
i think samantha carter is very hot
[Music]
i've noticed
several episodes where you and chris
seem to
have something going on it's weird i
don't know how to explain it but they
would bring the camera on the two of you
and it almost seems like a private joke
has occurred this is really what you
want i don't have a choice i will
destroy you i'm thrilled what's going on
there i'm thrilled you're getting there
it's rba has something to worry about
i think if he doesn't step up to the
plate and start you know
acting like a real man then maybe he
does have something to worry about
that's all i'm going to say
how come there isn't
what you call a carter doll from your
lips to the god of merchandising ears my
friend i mean i'm waiting for that
that's the one doll i would actually buy
hello dr weir
that's a serious question
that is so serious that um i can't
answer what other kind of genetic
surprises does shepherd possess us
besides his ancient genes
you know that um
that might be for another network
to talk about because
okay
who's the biggest distraction on this
set david eulet or rainbow francs
what that is really tough they are
head-to-head competing every day
for hey look at me
yeah
why haven't they written in more
women relationships for your character
i'm hoping that uh
you can stay for a while you know check
out the sights
it hasn't been really warranted we have
an episode that we just finished last
week
where o'neill gets kind of caught in bed
so we do know that he's you know has a
penchant for that kind of activity it
was a replica of yourself that would be
available but um
anatomically correct as well i'll do it
i am sorry i have to have today
that's coming out of your own little not
coming out of my head
very sick
[Music]
do you not need every able body to help
defend atlantis
i think we can handle it
is accentuated by a charlie's angel's
hair foot
see
i got a serious question okay yes how do
you guys go to the bathroom on atlantis
um i'm curious well taylor made sure
that the room that she got had its own
ensuite i i didn't ask that myself
someone someone else asked that they
wanted to know about the toilets yeah
yeah
weird people wanted to know about that
what is your name
[Music]
actually i'm kind of into the wraith
women
the marilyn manson yeah
i don't know something about her you
must feel hunger by now
i hear that you have a thing for the
race female
you think they're kind of sexy what is
that about
i think what is that about i just think
the wraith women particularly the keeper
there's something hot about her oh yeah
i think they're hot you're kinky yeah
you like that in you guys
no comment
we wouldn't be having this problem with
the damn alpha sight that we'd picked
hadn't been marked by the wraith they're
a real pain in the ass aren't they yes
they are will dr weir ever fight taylor
for shepherd's love because i'm
beginning to sense something going on
there we already have the looks that he
gives yeah no we've had a few bouts
already actually and you know she's a
fighter so she wins
so if it came down to that if it came
down to a real one-on-one um are you
telling me you can't kick her butt well
she i think we would have to revert to
really dirty tricks but she likes tayla
i mean they actually like each other so
it'd be a hard thing maybe they'll go
off
oh no another show sorry
interesting
[Music]
oh yeah i see you guys got the vip
switch that's what it's like to skate on
my board
what's up y'all not only will the down
oh you stupid rainbow
god this makes me feel like i'm vjing
again
[Music]
not only will low down give you behind
gates you will also see
other stuff i thought tonight i would
take a couple of the cast members from
sg1 out for dinner
[Music]
they had a nice room reserved for us to
eat in it's down here downstairs in the
cellar
and here it is it's the wine cellar in
the restaurant
they
put together this nice little cozy table
for us
and they'll be the three of us eating
tonight we're surrounded by some vintage
wine
and it's quite possible we'll drink
everything in this room tonight
this is jay akavone hey for those of you
who don't know how's it going
now did you make colonel are you still
major kowalski doesn't depend on which
which dimension we're in i believe it i
believe it doesn't matter
i think i'm major on major questions
major charlie kowalski yeah you guys
drink whatever you want it's in the
company
oh oh is that right yeah
what year what year is a crystal do you
have oh no they're a height restriction
in this moment
i see you guys got the vip switch
gulliver i'll be here in a minute they
saw two black guys come in and say no
downstairs
lord aries demands nothing short of
complete obedience from both you and
your people
yeah well i want ya
favorite guest star favorite guest star
eight years how many happened 200
episodes whatever the hell it was who
was well i think you know who our
favorite guest stars are because they're
the ones we still keep in touch with all
right
fake as hell hey what's going on there
he is
welcome hi wait wait get the bling what
time is it
what time it is it's only 20 to 10.
20 to 10. and rainbow just showed up
i didn't leave my phone you guys are
late i think we've said it numerous
times when when's the series gonna be
over it's a question that we're asked a
lot or
we're gonna have another year i think
it's gonna it will truly end when uh
we're not having fun anymore and when
the writers wanna run out of ideas and
that really hasn't happened
that definitely hasn't happened
do you think when the series does end
you guys will continue to work on
projects together oh god no hello i
don't even like these people
somebody [ __ ] fun
welcome to my crib uh let's yeah there
you go
there's not a lot of it would be
expecting me to be living like 50 cent
wrong i'm living like 25 cents but it's
okay
let's go right to this this is the
pride and joy of the
fridge photography
this is what every stargate fan wants
and every macgyver fan
[Music]
oh
loves
look at that outfit look at that hair
ricky d
uh yeah that's good times
i'm on international television now and
people all over the world know me
and
i'm living it up so when i got this
place the number one thing i was looking
forward to
was this view look at that
look at that view
okay well you get up at 4 35 o'clock in
the morning if you're lucky you get like
a half an hour workout at home and then
you come to work i'm here at six in here
in makeup and on set at 7 for rehearsal
shoot till one have a half hour for
lunch and then shoot till 7 30 8 o'clock
then i go home
and i do homework for an hour
learning the next day's lines my mind
was modeled after yours
is that why you left fifth
you know me as well as i know you
and then uh i go to bed
and then i get up at 4 35 o'clock the
next room and that's how glamorous it is
here come the camera
are you afraid to give me the camera
okay this is too expensive right on my
skateboard
oh hold the camera
how fast are you this is joe's leg
let's go we'll go slow
so what we want to do is get the feel of
what it's like to be on a board right
there we go okay come on
faster
[Music]
that's what it's like to skate on my
board
[Music]
you need to start trusting me jack no i
really don't the fate of the planet
depends on it
oh hi
you're also gonna see things like
going to happen next on stargate
atlantis what's going to happen on sg1
who's friends with who who are our new
enemies who are our
new family members and
who put that there
i two will be elated and others who will
be equally
upset we're doing some things that are
heavily character based that are sort of
lightning rod issues for many fans
online they seem to have very strong
polarized viewpoints on how they want to
see these things resolved or for that
matter
really don't want to see them resolved
in any way
this is the type of job that
could go on forever we've got another
order for
a ninth season i've always said that we
would only be limited by our
imaginations and we have such an
imaginative creative force
you're a
fruitcake
we do an episode called threads i was
kind of bugging the guys to answer a
question about daniel's ascension when
it when he left and died and went off to
wherever he went off to that we never
knew and i never knew episode called
threads we addressed the issue of what
kind of happened to him what decisions
made who he met along the way and what
uh what changed his mind and brought him
back to join the team on earth and in
this reality
there are some die-hards who prefer me
bald
[Music]
you need to start trusting me jack
no i really don't the fate of the planet
depends on it we continue to be excited
by it and enjoy it and and i get excited
about seeing the dailies for an episode
i've written or been involved with or we
we sit down and watch an episode when
it's finally coming together with the
music and the visual effects
if we all go wow that was that was
pretty good that's the best we can do
the scripts are going extremely well and
i have uh actually made a number of
suggestions um most of which have been
completely ignored that's a step above
where i was last year which was uh
you have not been practicing
sure joe and i are both capricorns
apparently we we should not get together
capricorns are not good apparently in
relationships
so you think it's worth checking out oh
well two is not capricorn
oh no don't you worry
taylor is not a capricorn the wraith are
slowly waking
soon this entire galaxy will be
embroiled in a war the likes of which
our generations have never seen there's
been a few speeches that were written um
in both the storm and the eye where
she's basically giving these speeches to
the people saying be prepared to die and
we're gonna fight until the last minute
and that's something she never would
have thought of saying eight months ago
we felt somehow it was appropriate this
is where it all started
and um
well you had something to do with this
and we're single-handedly gonna gonna
kill it so
that's why we're here really so it's
sort of it's like a full circle of life
there's the beginning and we're the end
of the circle of the circle exactly we
end the circle
if you're asking me something about the
the content and the storyline the arc
the
of this
franchise you're asking the wrong guy
i'm not quite sure what i have to do in
this next scene oh no i have to kiss
amanda that's right i have to kiss
amanda
i come in advance of the others but they
will be here soon oh my god
[Music]
i thought all you wanted was c4 and a
jumper why raid a city when you can
seize it
carter what do you want me to do call in
reinforcements taking on a system lord
[Music]
you cannot hope to defeat me
[Applause]
[Music]
you